if I multiply these the sky by eye and
do it repeatedly I could do the
arithmetic of these quite quickly right
so for example if said 2 equals I times
z1 right I'm gonna be a bit naughty I'm
just going to right across the page
because whiteboard because then you'll
see one second I'm just gonna get a 3i
plus I squared you agree with that so
what's the real part what so like that
first and then the imaginary part is
three on okay now if I go and do it
again is then free and say that's the
previous one and multiply it by I what
am I gonna get here well I multiply both
of these by I which gives me negative pi
plus 3i squared which is now what's the
real part in there - three very good -
three - I will do one last time Zippo if
I defines it for it is what happens when
I multiply the previous one by I again I
times Z three okay and then take this
guy and it's gonna get minus 3i minus I
squared
what's the real pot it's one one - yeah
okay now I know where all four of my
points are okay they are he here here
and here let's really quickly plot these
guys right
it's a chicken
this is it Jake
this is a absolutely as you will see
shortly multiply is not a good choice
for a common ratio it's a bit of a
boring choice in the same way that minus
one is a boring choice for a common
ratio fridge envy it still is but it's
not very useful one will get some more
useful ones later they're just
absolutely you can like it's a number
topics numbers are numbers so I can make
in my coronation
my first value of whatever I am have a
bit behind the eight ball so let's plot
this really quickly right three plus I
he's there is that one minus one minus
one plus 3i right is he - - three - I
went back - three - I and that shouldn't
surprise us because Zed 3 is the
negation of Z 1 is it not
so you can see I've gone all the way
around and then zip 4 1-3 yard okay
now the rotation here is not quite as
obvious the reason why I chose these
houses because I had the axes there that
make the rotation like oh there's no you
read 90 degrees to make it more obvious
here just like I did when we I try to
demonstrate what addition of complex
numbers was I'm going to draw in
intervals to the origin okay interval
here
yeah and now the rotation by PI on three
radians becomes very obvious do you see
it more clearly now right you've got
right angles happening everywhere here
right and each time you multiply by eye
you're going note that 80 clockwise by
pi onto just each time yes yes yes the
cave I'm so glad you said that right the
answer is yes and in case you didn't
quite catch that right think back to how
we'd be measuring angles in the past
right if you're doing say compass
bearings right varies how do we do we've
got lots at east-west II but how do you
do
three-digit true bearings where we start
from we start from North and then which
way do we count we can clockwise right
now the reason we start from North is
because on a compass like if you're
facing north that's the way you're
looking so it makes sense to start from
that way and we count clockwise because
well that's the way clocks count and
we're used to counting clocks see you
look at it you know okay that's the way
it goes
and then for some in comprehensible
reason when we transition to talking
about the unit circle and all that kind
of thing we say okay you know how you
starting up there just forget that start
over here and they're like what why
right
and then we say wait wait it gets better
don't just start in a weird spot I want
you to go in the opposite direction like
what would they thinking and the answer
is they were thinking this now sadly
most people you know don't get to see
this now you do and you can say
anti-clockwise has to be the way right
if you wants it to go clockwise
everything would be backwards in terms
of your negatives and stuff right sir
you can see x ones it takes you eighty
clockwise this no there's no like oh I
wonder which way we should go like the
coordinates tell you which way you
should go and the answer is it